please welcome the founder of martha
stewart
living omni media the one
and only martha stewart
wow
you are fantastic and where did you get
the best
no bs i walked into the dressing room
this morning and was like
what is this i have to have it before i
even knew
that it was your new signature vest
they're great and i have it on in red
and
uh it comes in in other colors but it's
our it's our best selling
piece of brown outerwear but i wear it
inside i call it the new sweater because
uh if you're in the car it's so nice and
cozy
if you're you know just walking down to
the chicken coops it's the perfect
thing there's such a great model thank
you
um by the way your new cover is so
beautiful
i don't mean to sound creepy but god
you're hot
do you know how hard it is to pull off
white pants
well i i i have good legs so it looks uh
i look good in that picture
thank you so much for holding it up like
that that's so nice
and i just wanted to tell everybody the
best by the way these vests are
available at
amazon the martha stewart shop on amazon
so
and i'm getting warm because i'm inside
in my
studio kitchen which i think is so
pretty and festive
you've got your and uh show you
[Laughter]
what do you want to talk about first
well i
actually was upstairs and we were
discussing this segment and i just
wanted to point out
um as i was just arranging a bunch of
your books
um in my own home you have
97 best-selling books
97 a whole library of books
having to do with good living good
cooking
good entertaining uh you know everything
uh gardening so we've been very busy for
the last 30 years making all this stuff
happen
can i ask you a question you know
recently and i wrote it on my arm so i
can like prove it to you
um i wrote on my arm all that you've
done
um i think this year in particular has
just been like no other and i know that
i'm incredibly privileged and
in a position that is too
fortunate and i had an epiphany an
aha moment a divine intervention this
sunday in the car
and i was thinking about all that i've
done in my life
and for some reason it just calmed me so
much
because i'm always thinking what have i
got to do i've got to do this i've got
to get that done
it's like a hamster wheel on fire and
like it never
really stops and do you think
that it's wise or coming to look back at
your life and think
i went to school i had a child i
had a best friend i i had a first job i
i did all of these things do you think
that could be an antidote to the sort of
pressures we all feel in order to make
our own lives work and happen
well i i'm not very introspective that
way
i really like to get things done i like
to move on to the next
fabulous project i love to come up with
new ideas
every single day i like to drive down a
new road
every day i am not i am an optimist
really and truly an optimist about the
world i think that
uh everything that happened this year
can be mended i think
we will survive we will
probably thrive in the next few years
so so that's the way i think and i i
know it's different from a lot of people
especially this year when people have
had a really
really tough time and if you ever have a
day where you're just
questioning everything do you tell
yourself something or do you just
feel like you can always put one foot in
front of the other
during this entire what is it nine
months i think almost
i have not stayed in bed past seven a.m
never and i have
um not really gotten drunk
and i have not done anything i don't
think anything really bad
but fun i've tried to have fun
and um and even though i know it's hard
it's hard it's hard there's always
something else to do
that'll get you through a difficult day
and that's the way i that's the way i
look at it but i was brought up by two
tough parents who would never let us
just
loll around and we can't mope we can't
get depressed we can't do any of that
stuff
yeah so that's that's um served me well
that makes sense martha stewart just
yeah
okay good i love that and i will always
put it into application and be inspired
by
you and i love that